alo alo cho các bạ
hôm nay on hơn muộn nhỉ một mình à Vừa
mới ngủ dậy hôm nay em mình à
Anh à Hôm nay phải lên công ty nên là
thời gian mình kiểu dạng là
à cậu à Chắc là cũng trong đoạn chuẩn bị
đơn trộn thôi
ừ ừ
à à
thì mình nghỉ sung nhé Mình nghĩ thông
cả làm trai hay con gái thì à em trước
30 tuổi tuổi mình về cơ bản vì có thể có
người
thì vẫn còn khá minh mẫn và và hoàn thời
gian này là thời gian mà chúng ta có thể
học kho cũng như là có thể trải nghiệm
nhiều cũng như là
khoảng thời gian này thì mình sẽ có Có
đấy Có sức khỏe rất nhiều thứ chả thiếu
mỗi tiền bạc rồi nhưng mà những cái khác
mình còn thời gian mình có mình có sự
nhiệt huyết mình sẽ đam mê các Xớ Rớ cái
thì nó gian này và mình không ngại học
hỏi vì không ngại thay đổi và thời gian
này thì mình và hoàn toàn có thể dễ tiếp
cận được những cái nguồn kiến thức mới
trải nghiệm với Vân
cho nên là trước 30 thì thì nên bận rộn
nên a ờ
cho nên bận rộn ở đây không phải mỗi bận
rộn công việc có thể là trải nghiệm đủ
kia mỗi người sẽ có một quan điểm khác
nhau muốn trở thành con người như thế
nào đó với các bạn thì ở góc nhìn của
mình thì hiện tại mình vẫn còn đang làm
à em đang còn lại Trẻ con vẫn còn đang
chưa chín chắn đủ bạn còn phải học hỏi
thêm nhiều
nên là mình vẫn tranh thủ đi học tranh
thủ từ việc à à
khoa học trải nghiệm Yoga
đọc thêm tài liệu không phải mỗi ngành
của mình mà Thậm chí Gần đây tôi là nó
đi học đàn đánh đàn em ạ Cho nó chút nào
rảnh dành một chút thời gian nào đó thì
mình nên thủ tận dụng nó Bạn thay vì
kiểu nằm cả ngày ở nhà không biết mình
nên làm gì để đỡ chán Vân thì mình nên
làm một cái gì đó Ừ cũng để giải trí đấy
nhưng mà nó có ích một cái gì đó thì tốt
theo theo mình nghĩ là như thế Tại vì
kiểu đầy nó trôi qua cậu lãng phí
Ừ ok thì đấy à Tâm Sự nhắn của mình
mình xin phép đầu tiên thì có bạn hỏi về
cái á
Ừ ừ cách lưu lại lưu lại ở đây là lưu
lại Việt Ví dụ nhé ví dụ thì công lý là
khi mà lên một cái video trên YouTube
không ạ Bạn ấn vào xem cái video gì đó
thì thì
sau khi mà ấn vào xong rồi Các bạn xem
thấy lượt xem nó có thể vẫn giữ nguyên
ngồi trước nó còn giới hạn được cho xem
thì 290 vậy Cái gì đó vẫn sẽ giữ nguyên
mãi ngầu
vài rồi sao hoặc là thậm chí ở một ngày
sau nó mới bắt đầu cập nhật Cái được xem
đúng ạ Nếu không có đi điều đấy không ạ
thì
ý thì cái vụ mà tại sao lại phải làm thế
anh không nó không phải lấy gì mất lắp
pin à
a people off Âm Nhạc
anh bởi vì ở cái kênh này hình ở tài
khoản tôi bị làm sao không không đăng
nhập được vào nữa
Em hãy có thể đăng nhập lại Facebook
phải
Em chả hiểu sao
hỗ trợ lý do đăng nhập lại để cho bé
uống xem
ừ ừ
từng nói qua mấy ông rồi đó là
đó là mình mình khi mà giống như tôi vừa
nói khi mà người dùng xem mà lập tức
mình cập nhật update ở trong d b là kiểu
tăng lượt xem D1 nó Ngoại Nghe có vẻ à Ừ
thì nó không hẳn nặng lắm đâu nếu mà que
theo ID thì họ sẽ ra nhanh nhưng mà bây
giờ
Ê mấy ông thường tạo đi chứ tốt và bạn
đang có bao nhiêu người đang xem ngay
ngay bây giờ mới ông nữa đúng không có
bao nhiêu người đang xem tâm diệt trừ
những cái gì mà cần phải hiển thị ra
luôn Giống như livestream như này thì
cần thì chị số view thực tế nếu mà Cá
Sấu Ghi thực tế mà càng ông nhìn kia thì
nó lại không phải là nó không phải đau
tao bay bình thường mà Mấy ông nó dùng
làm máy Ware mà nó lại là file page và
cái gì cái toppic xetai mà nó khác còn
nếu mà đã bay theo kiểu lưu lại thì
thường là nó không nên động
khi có biến động ở đây sao là không nên
kéo thay đổi liên tục như thế đặc biệt
là việc truy phần rất nhiều để thay đổi
như thế rất rất rất nặng
cho nên người ta làm ở đây là gì thì nó
sẽ khái niệm là đổi từ cái việc là đổi
từ việc là kiểu à Y Vân phi cơ Tất cả
chỉ là đây
khi mà khi mà cậu có một cái even một
cái sự kiện gì đó xảy ra bất chợt này
thì giả sử là gửi mail khi mà đăng ký
này xử lý video tạo report cái gì đó thì
nó cần xử lý ngầm để cho người dùng đỡ
phải đội thì cái đấy Tôi không nói nhưng
cái về việc là để mà update thì thực là
không cần phải
em không cần phải cập nhật số lượng view
sớm luôn ai lập tức nên nên là thường
thằng YouTube nó sẽ lưu lại tất cả những
cái Ok ông
Ừ ông kiểu dạng ông ạ
Anh nói như thế nào Bây giờ tôi sẽ cho
một cái ví dụ nhà cho người ông rõ hình
dung dễ hình dung tạo hàn cái test dành
cho lâu nha À test nha à a web này
Ừ đúng rồi nó sẽ lưu lại cách bạn này
hiểu đây đấy sẽ lại vào trong một cách
sau đó thì mình làm về Giờ tôi sẽ Giả sử
tôi truyền lên đây một cái đâu Cái chéo
nhé Cái ID của ai đi ngoại Dù ai đi của
video này chẳng hạn thế hãy đi video cho
mình sẽ cách lại như này
thì
mình sẽ à
à à
anh theo ID này à
ạ sau đó thì nó còn có thằng này còn có
cả hàng này luôn này
mặc định nó sẽ tăng lên 1
ở đây nó có hạn nhanh nhưng luôn
trò chuyện này đi làm nó để đăng lên một
ngày vẽ xong thế này là xong thức là sao
ngỡ là kiểu nó cứ mặc định tăng lên theo
đúng ai đi này
chị đã sử tôi thử EXO cái cách
xe Vespa là cho mày không xem nha à
ờ ờ
liên quan đến à
I miss the weather mình cần đâu mình đi
weather đấy thì tắt cái the weary sẽ
không đỡ
nuclear nào
ừ ừ
nó khiến nó Nó kiểu chạy vào Cái lỗi này
Em
quê ở đâu nhỉ
có
[âm nhạc]
hai ở trong cái file hepl mình vậy phải
hepl mình ạ
cho mọi nhiều do mẹ mày à
à à
Anh không thấy gì đây gây lỗi nghỉ hả
đây xem xem xem nó gọi từ đầu được
season Ghost này
I listen and owner
à à
đã thấy Bây này nữa thì tôi à
Vì thế tôi đổi ra ta bây giờ là nó sẽ
không có lỗi nữa Bây giờ tôi là tao bây
phải với về này
ừ ừ
mới ông thấy không thấy một điều là cái
cách này nó đang tăng liên tục để ông ạ
ở cách nhà Iran tăng liên tục
thì sẽ là lại quay lại là một đúng ạ pha
và đớn nhiên là cái này sẽ làm có tác
dụng tác dụng không phải để cho vui rồi
nó sẽ hiểu Khi mà tăng này xong rồi rồi
đến cậu nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ có bắt thời
gian đấy nó sẽ ra thời gian là kiểu
khi mặc kiểu đến một cái khoảng nào đó
nó sẽ lấy toàn bộ những cái cách đã lưu
đã lưu như thế này và cập nhật vào trong
tay một lần thôi thì mọi người sẽ thắc
mắc à Tại sao mất con lưu rồi
lưu vào trong cách làm gì anh lưu hỏng
chọn BB nó nhanh hơn thì ra là gì
con gà không lưu và kết nó nhanh hơn và
lực cách mạng dễ lấy ra nhanh hơn mình
thường làm bài toán là mình sẽ lưu lại
vào trong này
gì đó ví dụ là là xem video này nó sự
kiện này nó sẽ cộng một vào trong cách
sau đó thì đến một khoảng thời gian nó
sẽ lấy lấy toàn bộ trong cách ra không
phải chạy ngầm để cập nhật toàn bộ vào
trong đây một lần thôi chứ không phải là
mình liên tục gọi mình đã nên nhớ là mấy
ông truy vấn nói tao bay là khi vật nó
rất nhiều rồi bây giờ ông còn việc
update liên tục
Ừ cái việc update nó sẽ viết lại cả AE
nó sẽ cậu ảnh hưởng các thứ thứ Nếu
không hình dung đây là thấy là kiểu Nếu
mà ổn thì thì chúng ta nên về sau ở nên
cân nhắc việc đấy trong trường hợp mà
tôi em nói là bài toán nó lớn theo cờ
lại trang của ông ấy đến nhìn triệu kiểu
cầu Thế Truy cập thì thì sẽ cậu của phải
cân nhắc việc là lưu lại
À thỉnh thoảng mới lưu lại không cập
nhật kiểu liên tục liên tục liên tục ở
sẽ chết tay Ngài không hình trong không
ạ
ý thì cái vụ mà lưu cao View ý tôi à là
mình có thể xử lý phải toán như thế tiếp
theo thì có bạn bảo là
em có bạn đấy cũng hỏi là ờ
ở lại một lần nữa cho tôi khẳng định về
dịch vụ là là
toán bởi những cột khác đặc biệt là
những cột khác nó thay đổi thì cái giá
trị ở đấy nó lại phải cập nhật
ra để dễ hình dung hơn nó ra nào giống
như kiểu các bạn lưu lại cột + lưu lại
cột tổng tiền thì trong hóa đơn thì các
không sao thì cái hóa đơn và gần như là
cố định là nó không thay đổi nhưng mà
bạn không không lưu lại cái kiểu
Ừ thế nào nhỉ những cái gì thay đổi tự
nhiên tôi
anh nói chung là không lưu lại cột mà
thể tính toán bởi những cột kia thôi Tôi
không nhớ Chính xác cái ví dụ này lắm
nha Hôm nay bạn có hỏi đấy thì tôi phải
nốt lại để nói lại nhắc các bạn 1 lần
nữa tránh việc các bạn tạo ra tay nó bị
sai
hào đây thì hôm nay tôi định à Các bạn
thấy cái tiêu đề hôm nay sẽ review lại
code cũ thì xem lại toàn bộ cốt mình xem
mà cài trang web của mình có dễ dùng hay
không là tôi đang thuế Thật ra trang web
của tôi không hề dễ dùng gì cả Và và
vừa dậy dùng nhé là kết hợp việc là là
thêm với gì là không
Ừ Ok bạn chỗ mà vừa vào thì mình cần đầu
tiên mình xem lại toàn bộ bài đăng cũ
này thì hôm hôm trước tôi Mình nhớ ra
một cái chân lý đó là một cái sự thật à
là ví dụ Giả sử các bạn vào trang này để
mà xem bài tuyển dụng đúng chứ thì các
bạn đang
con gà các bạn không phải Peter mỗi mấy
cái này khó Exciter mỗi cái kiểu là là ở
đây thiếu thiếu một cái phi tơ Ngôn ngữ
này
Ừ đúng ạ một lần Phi ta cho ngôn ngữ
đúng không hay là thứ Peter theo cái
trình độ của các bạn đó là vectơ Yugioh
Sino
em không có xong rồi lít hoặc cả thật
cao hôn gì gì đó nữa Ở đây không có mới
chỉ có theo không thời gian các thứ thứ
ra thì ra sai nhà mình xin phép và hôm
nay mình sẽ phải đầu tiên phải sửa lại
từ bên này đã là phải có cấp độ cho cái
cấp độ cho cái bài đăng
bố mẹ các bạn hình dung mình sẽ phải có
cấp độ cho cho các bài đăng này và phải
có và giả sử nó sẽ rửa mặc định so với
chủ đề được ạ khi mình thêm thì định nó
sẽ tưởng nằm trong tiêu đề luôn Ví dụ
giả sử như ai hai bên mình Cậu chọn ngôn
ngữ ngay sau đó tự động tạo tiêu đề ngày
đúng ạ Đáng lẽ là nó sẽ phải là Yugi Oh
ở đằng trước như này chẳng ạ vừa sướng
ra chúng yêu nha à Xong rồi cách nhanh
nha Hồ Chí Minh này nó sẽ Kiều
thì nó sẽ kiểu trong đó tường minh hơn
kiểu kiểu Thế theo như tôi nghĩ là như
thế
Ừ Ok nghỉ giờ mình sẽ thử làm nhé
Anh làm bên admin đúng không sẽ xấu view
amin xong rồi bài đăng
có thêm mình sẽ có đúng rồi mình phải
thêm cột mà trong cái A bài đăng này nữa
ở cột mà sẽ là bởi vì như các bạn vừa
nghe rồi ra thì à Ờ một bài đang nó sẽ
có nhiều cấp độ đúng không ạ
Ừ
đúng rồi có thể công ty tuyển tất cả
tuyển từ nhà thiếu hết
miễn là làm cái
khi sex
Ừ miễn là làm cái ngôn ngữ đấy là được
từ Junior EXO DO đến cuscino ta tuyến
hết có những công ty tuyển là EXO với họ
không phải công ty Chị tuyển khác sơ Mở
bài đang đấy thì tiền festa thôi Chẳng ạ
để mà Bởi vì nó có cái file để yêu cầu
hacker chẳng hạn thế nhưng cũng có kiểu
và ngược lại sẽ có những cái bàn ăn chỉ
Tuyển simeone thôi ông ạ tôi là level
đây nó sẽ rất là linh hoạt tinh Hoạt thì
cái theo mình nghĩ thì level đây sẽ là
một cụt nữa và cụ đấy có thể phép được
nun nó ra cho phép cao nghĩa nếu món
luôn thì tất cả không chị ạ mọi level
còn nếu mà là sự là lyvo
Ừ nhưng mà có những bài đăng nào có kết
hợp cả 2 level nhé Có cả chị từ faster
You Know cho đến siêu có chẳng hạn thì
mình sẽ phải
thì mình sẽ phải có lưu lại
ở đây mình tính xem một là lưu lại theo
kiểu dạng là mỗi kiểu dạng như thế này
anh như thế này
mình sẽ là chuỗi nên để kiểu số để in a
mà mình nghĩa là như thế
chuỗi là dạng số của cái không ạ ạ
này để ấy năm cũng được
3000 i5 là số nhiều trong một bài nữa là
số nhiều vừa rồi ở Nếu thế để dạng chuỗi
đi ừ
chợ
hoa các bạn có thể cần nhớ rằng vụ làm
mạc Nhưng mà thực ra cái mảnh này nó hơi
ngắn thì không muốn làm lắm
web môi giới này à
ở đây sẽ có m = enter
có luôn level u
ừ ừ
Ê Mày đang ở đâu bộ thôi
tu posts
a
table à
thì mình sẽ chạy cái file này
các bạn thể xem có linh anh nhé
bộ phim sex
à à
áo
có form e
các vì sao Level của nó vừa gợi ý là Chữ
level
ở đây FO
a Payphone không không cần có defoe
loanable và sau Cột nào
ca nhạc bolero đây đã sao Coca
em
thừa cột này khá quan trọng ngày mình sẽ
để sao chép hay thổ luôn à à
anh
mất tay vào đây này
cũng được thì thích cậu à
the manor
i
love travel
vì vậy ý ra hai đứa dễ hiểu
Vì
thế tôi sẽ để lấy bồ đây như này nó hiểu
nó xuống nhiều đi cho nó dễ đi
ừ ừ
tên file như này rồi anh em nay có sửa
đổi tiền tao không sửa được
Ê bà xã shd rồi
Ừ Tôi muốn đặt tên lạ wi-fi này nhìn này
cho nó thương binh ok
khi đó Bệnh giờ mình sẽ thử chạy Xong
rồi sẽ thử lại nha
ở đâu toàn bộ bài đăng này sẽ đang là
trống level Thực ra thì
ừ nếu thế thì ngày cái lúc mà mình bóp
vào ấy lúc import toàn này
vụ mà là tôi sẽ Dung ạ gì
nhở tôi sẽ dùng Ô đổ đây thứ hai là tôi
sẽ kiểu hiển thị ra cho mấy ông xem cái
kiểu ý
[âm nhạc]
bình thường à trải nghiệm người dùng ở
đây nó không tốt ở điểm này khi mình
inbox vào nó không review nó không hiển
thị lên là mình đã Insert được bao nhiêu
tháng đúng chị ạ cũng như là hình chị dữ
liệu sẽ Insert nó sẽ là gì Kêu việc là
cái hợp việc là mình đang không chọn mặc
định mặc định là mình đã không chọn À
đây ví dụ giả sử như trong trường hợp
này tôi có rất nhiều kiểu
ở những nhiều công việc nho công việc
này công việc của
Pasteur và Junio chẳng hạn thế họ mày
không thấy ở đây rồi cái sơ Junior đúng
không Bây giờ tôi tải lại file nhé
mô tả lại lại cho chắc ở nhà đúng không
ạ Thi
Ừ thì bèo khi mà tội inbox thì tôi cần
là hiểu là tôi sắp import toàn bộ bài
đăng cho Festival và chuno Tức là sao
nghĩa là tôi cần là
chủ nhật đi ăn một cái mô đồ ở đây nó lá
nó hiển thị một cái mô đồ đây để tôi
chọn
xe tải cẩu như thế Tôi chọn là trước là
Level của cái cái file tôi sẽ anh post
nó là level gì cho tôi inbox vào thì nó
mới đồng loạt kiểu linsơ vào có dấu hiệu
ạ Còn bây giờ thì à
ừ ừ
à à
mạng sau thay đồ ngay lại nhỉ
a-class này ấn vào nút import này
Tình Yêu Của Tôi
Ý em sao
ấn vào nút import này thì bản trước là
mình sẽ cân à
thế hiển thị ra rồi cái mô đồ không ạ
thì tôi sẽ lấy cái mô đồ từ bên này cho
nhanh à
đút chắc mình đang dùng Wechat mấy cho
bố chập ba hiện nay
khi click này đấy mà nó sẽ nhảy ta ghét
mà sao mày có bị về nè
à à
em sửa lại cái Thái Tổ nó đủ
tiếng sau có
dự án ơi thế thì
Ừ cái này ngay
mua đồ đấy sẽ là
mua đồ
a cp1e
Ừ chắc thế này đâu nhỉ xem nha à
ấy
mua đồ CP
mình sẽ có
Đã lâu lắm rồi này Nội dung ở giữa này
inbox CP
cái này nó sẽ là mình rất cái này vào
đây này
chị sẽ có một cái đầu tiên pha như này
Thế Hiển thị giao cảm là cái Chọn Pha
này
Á và một cái nữa sẽ là ý nghĩa tôi sẽ
vứt vào trong cái phom phom ở đó thì nó
sẽ hợp lý hơn à
xe tải
từ hôm đi này
I from Heaven zona
ừ ừ
ở
Móng Cái
ở đít này
thế này thôi nha
thì
tại sao
thiếu tướng Ok này
Ừ thế Tại sao mua thẻ thổ nó bay sang
bên này nhá cho muốn cưới
Ừ thế thôi Cái này mình
Á hậu Thụy 310 luôn
thì mình sẽ cho chọn level đã
Anh được không quan trọng tiếng Anh
tiếng Việt mình sẽ mất một cái mô đồ
Ừ anh em ấy Cái i5 là level Sports label
thế này
có
thêm chửi năm rồi đó
Ừ nó
à à anh ở đây sẽ là
a what I năm nay
thì mình sẽ có lắp nick constant anh sẽ
ra
a
chun eo
gợi ý sự thật ở sinnoh
Ơ hay
ở công ty
ừ ừ
buýt đâu chẳng hạn ạ
aa33 Yasuo Gia Xử chuyện này à cả facial
nữa
khi exo
Anh
Tạm thời như thế nhỉ rồi còn cái Ngó xem
lại là cái file đấy những công việc gì ạ
e-reader next row này giảng viên luôn
này like cho
thì chắc là cũng à Đi đâu thôi
à trâu à Manager chẳng hạn là xử thế
Malaysia đúng không ở ngân hàng châu Âu
sẽ là sáu đi rất nhiều loại thìa
Ừ mình đây sẽ làm một cái xe lách
selects lấy một loạt ốc chân ra để hiển
thị thôi thì
Ừ cái này bởi vì a tôi thấy cái năm này
nó
Em nói sao
ừ à nó không được dùng nhiều nó có dùng
tạm ở đây đã
em có thủ công truyền thủ công ở đây vậy
Lúc này Index này lấy
lego
bằng Booth pro
- 5 này
em Gợi ý dẫn sự thật
xala Ở đây toàn bộ ra này
em nói chuyện với bố mày ngủ ở nhà hay
xong
nhà đây sẽ là
ô oh and I
I
asked you
à à
Ừ cái này là gì nhỉ à
khi mà lạ Ừ cái lên đâu nha
Ừ cái này là cái hiển thị bên cái này
cái bên trái cái bên phải cái này Peru
và cái này sẽ là cái
à Cậu Ốc Sên 22
này à
à mà ở đây sẽ mình sẽ sửa lại tí Nếu mà
nhớ mẹ aina giỏ ngày thì mới ông sẽ thấy
là hỏi Nam viết hoa hết trong một giờ
xấu
trò chơi nhảy
Em hãy Tôi đã sửa lại thì nó là class
xem nào ra form control ô này ạ là không
con trâu này là tiếp theo là tôi muốn
kiểu cho viết thường hết rồi cái hoa mỗi
chữ cái đầu thì
chuyên à
thế này và ờ ờ
em mới gọi đấy được không
thì bà gọi
vì nó có các đi tô vậy
là là viết hoa Bộ chưa cái đầu mình nhỉ
à à
em giờ không cần phải ghi lại đâu Hình
như thế thử xem nhé
A Gọi inbox thẳng luôn mà gọi được mà
ít Mây
ở đây
sản xuất trai tơ
à à
thế Thế thì đoạn này sửa thành nhà ạ Cát
Bi tồ nhanh Trinh à
à à
anh không không dùng hết hepl làm gì cả
khi mà
HP có sẵn rồi Capital sinh này
a what I
ừ ừ
vi
phạm gì đi khách sau ngay
à à quên đôi quen phải cho cái này chọn
nhiều sẽ là multiple đã cho phép chọn
nhiều
ai ngờ cho phép chọn nhiều thằng ngày
thì mới Ông thấy hơi xấu nên à và tôi
thấy à Cái này thích hợp được cái thằng
à chích hai nữa thì ngon thì tôi sẽ kết
hợp C khai luôn cho thằng ngày sẽ là
Em đừng có ý nữa
à
nho đúng đấy
Kết quả
nó nó hiểu là mình sắp Cl2 thật là à
ở trọ mà
ở kiểu ngày xong rồi
hai vợ chồng chưa gặp này sẽ chọn hai
cái đúng ạ chọn cái này nằm trước sau đó
khi mà
sau khi mà chọn xong thì
Ừ
cái xếp vn Channel
vì tôi nghĩa nên có cái nút ở đây thì
bạn xem ít chứ không phải file là thay
đổi thì nó xem ít nó chưa kịp chọn cái
level này sắp biết rồi không tốt mình sẽ
có một cái bớt tần ở đây
các clip ở đây à
anh
là một kẻ có tâm sẽ Cậu này ba
inbox cho nhắn à
thế giới hiệu là kiểu Em bấm vào nút này
thì Post không ạ
a-class nó đi nó là tinh thần sexy
anh nghe đi
em gái
à à
D3 gì nhỉ Khi nút này được Bấm thì
ai điên lúc này là một tuần
import
sẽ về ông ạ à à
sau khi núi này được bấm
Mở
mic này
thì có cái phone truyền For trong này
chuyển dữ liệu vào
con gà Nếu thế thì tôi cho cặp đấy
xe ôm ôm hết hàng ngày cho nhanh
chuyển thêm cái không phải di trong
chiều mày không phải rít nữa sẽ cụ thể
đây là
thế này
ạ
sẽ lấy cũng từ lego
là
cậu phải ghi rõ là sage vô dễ hiểu tụi
mình truyền lên
Ừ Để tao thử nhé
Có ý dùng Red II
à à
cách chọn pha lê này
khi mình bấm lên rồi đúng không
em không đi sida
nó báo lỗi rồi
anh không tìm thấy
à à
anh gọi thì đợi thì không tìm thấy đây à
a level
à
nhầm nhầm nhầm
wi-fi nữa bạn này value ngay thôi
lưu truyền đây này
theo dõi
a sport đẩy lên này để lên về xử lý rất
là nhanh nhưng mỗi tội là ở
đâu đợi tí led này import này thì đây
trong trường hợp này thì mới Ông thấy là
mình sẽ phải truyền lên cái nữa nha cách
tốt thì tôi sẽ đặt tên là đây đã tên
kiểu ngay cho khi mà có tầm hai cái nên
kiểu khai báo dữ liệu như nhưng ở đây đã
được ngủ đây
dùng cái input input hơn là dùng ghét
phim hài
nó có luôn đấy
âm nhạc có cái á
Nhớ ở lao khuyên là nên dùng cái request
gọi đến phút hơn là dùng cái ghép có ghi
hẳn cho comment ở đâu đấy tôi quyền sử
rồi à
không nhớ
7 vứt ở đâu rồi ý
ở nhà nên dùng cái này
nó như nhau nhé hỏi nhau nhé phút rồi
Ghét đều được
U20 speak leaving ở trong ngay là ở đây
mình sẽ
em có chút ích này
a string mình trở lên chuỗi mà level này
à
a shopaholic
Ê con chó óc khởi tạo nghĩa là khi mình
truyền và những cái kiểu như này thì nó
sẽ con chắc
mình sẽ có truyền level xong nhé anh là
mình sẽ đưa rít vì bồ bằng Devil nhớ ai
mà ở dưới này mình sẽ mình sẽ cậu
chưa nào nó nhập vào trong mộng cái bài
đăng này thôi Một bài đăng này mình sẽ
có thêm một cái level đây nữa
à à
thì mình sẽ có level u
anh ở đây sẽ là đôi axit gọi level
nó hết Xong tôi hình như tôi vừa nói
inbox ta lại tất cả là anh muốn đóng vai
đang ngồi
không chạy như vậy
à à
tối hôm chưa Tôi không sửa nhớ sửa mày
nghỉ ở trước sửa chỉ có trách năm week
lại không phải có đây nè nghỉ
nhờ chưa Chưa làm gì vậy
Ừ thế hỏng ấy mình phải làm cái hãy mình
phải lưu lại đã tổ chức là có ngôn ngữ
nào cho nhà không
a Project language
một thằng trung gian nữa là thằng à
à à
cho anh sướng mới
agribot này
Ừ sandwich
quý rồi nhỉ
ừ ừ
tạo có lúc nghỉ import thì mẹ không nhập
vào máy xay
report này thì mình sẽ phải nhập vào
Hà
Nội Tôi nói tôi I
anh nghe Thằng này nó sẽ là
Anh
đang viết bằng
object đi
à à
Ừ Ok chưa
a boss
một ở các ông dùng chỗ này hay là thằng
là bản chất hành newark cái thuê ship
của nó nó có cái vụ có thằng để mà trung
gian rồi có nhớ có hỏi vụ này
ờ ờ
A gọi đến toàn bộ của nó để nó xếp này
anh như này xếp many luôn đấy
a many-to-many nha Attack như này để
chuyển vào nha
Ừ nhưng mà cái mấy cái này nó nhận như
tôi từng bảo nó bị khó hiểu
sai này khó hiểu kiểu thủy thủ công
nhưng được không sao cả
Ừ Ok đợi tôi xem nào
số
trang web chuyên lao
Anh hello
ở
đầu tiên là tôi phải xóa lại cái file đã
ô mai
ờ ờ
I bought xa lại xóa này
Ừ giời import lại nha
em có bạn ơi
toàn bộ bài đăng lên này có trách
language có này
Ê mày đang này có 81
tổ chức năng which là 900 ở chỗ là đủ
đấy
file 81 Ok hôm nay
a post or thêm level 12 12 12 OK OK được
gọi thì bây giờ mình sẽ
Ừ Ok em Bây giờ
mình phải sửa lại cái góp thay đổi nữa
quên quên
anh không Mình phải mình sức khỏe của
tôi thì có khác nhỉ
Ừ mình không đấy mình đặt tên là mỗi này
nghe thật là thiếu
như thế nào nhỉ
khi crit thì cũng cho phép chọn level đã
xe janus Thái Thù này
Ừ nó là
anh đấy Đấy Bây giờ tôi phải có comment
ở đây ở dễ hiểu cái vụ hay thù đi
thì mình sẽ có City
a City language
em gửi gì đây không không phải có ý kiến
gì tính thế
I see til I
ừ ừ
à à
nghe
level u
có ship gạch ngang City này
ạ sau đó thì à cách là làm một loạt
language chức
ạ sau đó đi gạch ngang nữa Company Nếu
Có ạ cổ phần y nó đầy đủ sẽ nhìn này đấy
Ừ thì ở bên này cũng thế Cái này thì có
tôi nghĩ tôi sẽ tạo một cái Hàn
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
từ lúc mà mình flash thì mình cho người
dùng truyền thay thổ thật có mỗi lúc
import này
Ừ thì mình cậu phải tự xin hàng ngẫu
nhiên thôi tôi sẽ có vai vế ở lại đi vài
vết Phương Trinh
ý
là generate
your title à
thế này
này thôi mình là level I
a company
cho
nó những truyền tất cả vào trong ngày
Anh xóa đi mình nào để xem nha không còn
đi đâu rồi không có đi ai đi đấy
lên đây đi
làm mình sẽ suy tôn
ờ ờ
ở đây có một cái đó là level này mình sẽ
phải convert nó ra thành chỗ ấy đã rồi
tí đi tìm
đây sẽ là Android này
không hoặc bằng
[âm nhạc]
ở chỗ trống này
Em thích day level
ở đây safary
a boss
ở level li5 này
A Z
và lục
Ê con kia là ngon cái level này chụp
cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy
này à
đã truyền thêm vào
Ừ Đợi thì đợi thì đợi tôi một tí nhá
Tôi không thích cái việc thừa do phải ở
quấy
anh có thể biến cái đây này
lệ đã
Anh remix
anh hiểu
và sẽ là nơi mát uhh
khi
con chân
từng tháng 1 nhân 2
thì mình sẽ with ơn về
thế này nó thế này nói chuẩn này
Ừ rồi zê zê là thằng Hà Nội thằng level
3 này cho mấy ông dễ hiểu nha Không mấy
hôm nữa không hiểu tôi làm gì ta ừ
anh vẫn Từ từ đợi tí
từ Translate
chạy thử ngày thật đây này à
à à
em chạy lại này ừ ừ
khi ngâm sẽ thấy là
thông báo lỗi không rồi
Ừ cái
à à
làm đúng về
Ừ đúng nhà thằng á
à À cái này là chuỗi bằng ghét Zalo này
nó lại kiểu yêu cầu
số thì ra nó chuỗi gì đó thôi Tôi để nó
chuỗi nhé
à à
ở nhà chúa đi nó sẽ không bị cái lỗi kìa
mình phải còn bớt ra số nữa
mình mình đây thổ cái á
ở level
balo này ra thì ở sẽ convert nó giao
hàng
anh xin lỗi em
Anh xin lỗi nhé
Ừ đợi tí để thử thằng sẽ mã á
Đã kết Zalo thằng này đúng rồi nhớ thì
đợi tí tôi một ký
ờ ờ
Ừ đúng rồi ghét kia đúng
nhầm nhầm nhầm nhầm nhầm
như vậy và Blue là để rồi khi
nhầm hai thằng này với nhau
à Mẹ ơi Này karaoke
tôi là đúng chứ thằng Đúng vậy
Ừ nó EXO soon ok rồi sau đó Thì bây giờ
mình mới kiểu à
ở level u
ngày à
à à
Mình dùng Win nữa mày không Mình cho
quen ubutu lắm em à Mình chưa dùng một ô
tô bao giờ tính ra thế Mình dùng bạn làm
ở mình dùng Line up a
ạ
ông
Lê cô này
City này
City sau đó thì cách ra này language
or Company name trong trường hợp Company
name có thôi còn không thì
ngày tôi viết theo kiểu nhà đi
thứ ngày
đúng không
city city lúc nào nôn nôn
City có thể không có thì mình sẽ là
I eat
v-app CT e
a di truyền thêm vào như thế này
mà khó bạch nhan ra truyền thêm này sau
đó thì à đóng ngoặc này
nó chuẩn luôn này sau đó thì
Anh quay quá xịn
ở hai xã sẽ là
ảnh
hot girl truyền thêm ngay thôi language
này rồi Có thì nó sẽ
làm ngay à
anh ở đây này người dễ hiểu hơn
à à
thế này sẽ là chóp
sao mình sẽ truyền nó vào ngày ok
ở đây đây rồi nằm chót hay thôi mình sẽ
hiểu nhé Ae
bộ chiến sĩ nào Đông
Ừ Thế chịu nổi I
cách cá mập cá ở đây
show thường vô cách ở đây gửi cho khách
ở cuối rồi nhỉ
Ừ ok không sao thì không sao
nó rồi
cái đi
ok ừ
mất công lại ngồi import một đống này
Họ đáng lẽ là mấy thằng này nên bị tác
động khi mà mình xóa toàn bộ bài đăng
liên quan thì nó sẽ bay theo
Ừ ừ
đài phải làm cái kiểu nó sẽ kiểu ở con
kia nhưng kiểu kiểu dạng là không phải
widget ngày nữa mà sẽ lạ Các sếp này sẽ
ổn hơn
thế hệ tôi sẽ cho tất cả những lời bay
theo vậy nhé
chứ không phải đi chí còn này nữa
mm này
à à
ờ ờ enter
ê lùn onekey
Honda Lead us
à à
rất là hay này ờ
ở đây nha
đang muốn
à Tôi đang muốn thay đổi thay đổi cái
phone key này có cái bảng này đang từ
kiểu mặc định mặc định của nói sẽ là lý
trí tất cả sao là là nó đang kết nối cái
thằng này với thằng cha rồi đúng không ạ
Và khi khi mà có thằng con như thế thì
thằng cha không được phép xóa gần như
trong trường hợp đây này anh sẽ không
được xóa gì cả nó báo bởi vì nó vui
chích Tức là nó sẽ nhắn lại không Không
cho xóa theo Giả sử Tôi muốn xóa toàn bộ
hoặc cha và toàn bộ những thằng con có
thể nó sẽ bay theo thì mình sẽ phải mình
sẽ phải cậu đổi cái này thành các tên
như thế này này đấy thì thì thì mình sẽ
hiểu được phép xóa cả thằng cha vậy
thằng con nó sẽ chọn được xóa luôn
Ừ Thì trong trường hợp mà các bạn muốn
đổi như thế thì chỉ có thể các bạn dốc
Cái con kia của tất cả mấy tháng ngày và
cập nhật lại phone khi cho nó chứ không
trường hợp cập nhật bình thường mà là
lốp song với
Cập nhật lại thì cái á
hướng dẫn các bạn giúp nó Thiên thường
là trên trên công ty như là các bạn vừa
thấy mình làm là mình sẽ không bao giờ
kiểu ngồi trại câu load thẳng luôn Mà
mình sẽ phải khi mà thêm thêm sửa xóa
một cái gì thì mình luôn phải kiểm tra
xem nó còn tồn có tồn tại không thì mình
về phép thêm sửa Giả sử chưa tồn tại
mình thêm nếu mà giờ sử tồn tại rồi thì
mình sửa và đây trong trường hợp này
mình phải kiểm tra xe Ford để có tồn tại
thì mình mới xóa thì bờ cái câu lệnh để
mà kiểm tra cái có tồn tại thì mình sẽ
ghép
em trả lại thì cốt cũ của mình Mình
không nhớ lắm đã
che con kia
I dislike
Anh không dùng để balo để ai đó chúng ta
không
à à có câu truy vấn này
để có cái con này rồi hồi trước không có
cơ
Ồ tôi toàn phải chạy đâu lấy lít danh
sác ạ
kia lại dễ á Không nó là muốn có thế
thôi
kiểm tra nhanh cái À cho nhanh nhỉ trai
Hình như cái Hàn vừa rồi Đúng rồi cái
không phải ghi đúng rồi
anh như thế này
Ừ rồi đấy ạ
test catalo mà mình sẽ biết mà ngoại đổi
cái này lại
ừ ừ
ở
bảng mình lấy từ bảng file đi
à à
Ừ vậy thôi nha
Ừ anh em lắm
a web môi giới F
key của khách hàng kia
à À quên
có sửa sửa lại cái áo
em sửa lại cay chút
anh chạy bên web đấy à
I walk Tracker
Ừ vậy thì tại sao trách nhỉ
đây đây đây đây tôi dùng cái
a fine
Hì hì ngờ không khác gì vừa rồi sao
à à Không cái này là
mở mạng cho về mặt Ok Ok nói sao lại
mạng đấy mẹ không phải
cô gái giờ mình sẽ dùng nó như này thì
sẽ dùng nó như này
anh ở nhà
Ừ ừ Dada
xong ngồi
mình sẽ có
bắt chước như bên này đi
nó schema nhưng ai
các bạn phải đây đúng không ạ
thì mình sẽ kiểm tra ít
Ừ nếu mà nhưng mà đây ngược lại lại sẽ
là pha nhà ok rồi Cái này sẽ là nếu mà
có thì mình sẽ
a parent
thế này
nữa nhé Ok này ạ sau đó thì mình sẽ tạo
lại cái phone kia nó
khoa học file word
hai iPhone Key
notable này
Xóa mày đi này
thì mình dốt bỏ đi này do mình tạo lại
như này
và tiếp theo đây kiểm tra có tồn tại thì
mình mới Lốp nó rồi chạy lại mới nhá Còn
không thì là không chạy thôi
ờ ờ
luôn cho kiểu Giả sử là khi mà cô dâu bị
xóa nữa nhưng mà chắc là tôi không mở 6
giờ đâu em cứ thích kiểm tra nên làm thế
thôi à
gì tương tự Thế nhà mình về có phải đúng
không tưởng thế mình sẽ có cái bên A
mình khác đi bên ốc czech language không
ạ Nhưng sẽ có liên quan đến thăm nhà
liên quan đến hàng poster Ừ rồi không
liên quan hành posts
anh xóa còn gì nhỉ Chị đã giả mình thì
mình sẽ phải chạy câu lệnh nozzle của
công thôi thì mới xóa
anh Bởi vì nó đâu nấu khó ngoại rồi nhỉ
Ừ nó không nó có ngoại
khi người ta chỉ đơn giản này thôi cập
nhật
Cái này thôi
anh em rồi à
cột phone kia rồi Thế mình phải khôi
phục quốc ta vừa nãy cốt mà nó gợi ý như
mình chảnh không đấy
anh tí Đợi thì tạo một tí
I
for int
Em có xài đi
iPhone iPad on Fox
à à
Ừ ok rồi tôi ta lại cái này thì bây giờ
nó sẽ là catset như này tức là sao nghĩa
là mỗi lần mà tôi có rất nhiều file được
ạ nhưng mà giờ sự tôi xóa toàn bộ bài
đang thì toàn bộ phái bay theo đó ok
mỗi ngày mỗi ngày biết thêm một cái mới
đúng không
à à
hi vọng mày cái này không đủ họ không
trả không hẳn là khó gọi tôi không Nghĩa
dùng từ khó hiểu mày chờ đứa nào mới về
mấy ông thôi
thì ib em trả lại nha
à à
sự thành công này
an toàn bộ file lên này một bộ bài đăng
lên heo này chót 2 hồ xịn chơi này ok
chưa shochu yofaso rất nhiều lắm chị ạ
Bây giờ bên đây này
Em chỉ cần sẽ xem được
à À đúng rồi
Ừ nó chưa được cấp rồi phải Hình như là
chấp lose
nhớ chưa được tính chất vui vậy
à à
không phải Superman thằng Toàn bộ bài
đang chơi với tôi tôi sẽ thử đổi hạn
anh nghe bài được gặp luôn
ở đây này
ok rồi đấy ạ Bây giờ mình à
Vì sao buổi ốm sao mình sẽ chữa tiếp với
cái vụ là lọc theo
ở
level ở bên này kết hợp với việc là kết
hợp với việc là là lọc theo ngôn ngữ nhé
bữa hôm nay chắc là
buổi hôm nay chắc là kiểu tương đối thế
rồi mình dậy thêm cho các bạn thì như
bạn thấy là hôm nay chắc là dạy thêm
Được cái khoản là là là
kiểu thể post level này
em sửa lại một tí thứ thôi
chủ yếu là cái biết thêm được cái mới là
cái vụ là mình sẽ kiểm tra xem là cái
cái này nó kiểm tra cái Index nhá nó
kiểm tra được nét chấm kiểm tra được gặp
Ricky cái nói chung nhà kiểm tra for key
có thể thứ có tồn tại không được để làm
gì để mà dốt nó thực ra là cái cái này
nó bị buồn cười một điểm là cái cái cốt
thế Mình nhớ không lầm này thì cốt này
không hẳn là kiểm tra phone kia đâu mà
chỉ kiểm tra
warranty thôi chẳng qua lại em chẳng qua
là kiểu ở
Ừ hai mẹ ông đọc lên đấy cả chẳng qua
lúc mà tạo con kia nó ta tự động tạo
Index thôi nên may mà kiểm tra được chứ
còn nếu là sự ông xoáy đã cử trong cái
này đi Chẳng hạn mà phone kia vẫn còn
thì cái cốt này nó không chạy được đâu
nhé nghe về sau không biết được mấy ông
có dính quả bất lợi không là tôi đã nói
trước là như thế Ok không ạ
em gái mình
Em yêu hôm nay mình chỉ cập nhật được
Cũng không hẳn là nhiều lắm nhỉ
ở nhà tại lô gic một tí và cách sửa các
thứ thôi
em
có bạn nào có thắc mắc gì nhỉ à
Ê mày xem
anh cũng vẫn gọi là đông nhưng mà cũng
à Chắc quen rồi
Ừ ok bày cách cách kho mít luôn à
- 5 này để tắt kia này
ở đây 7 tầng thằng này lên một nhà
Vì
sao đó thì mình bắt đầu một xưởng mua đồ
này
ý là như này sao đổi mới bắt đầu Kiều
liên quan đến controller
khi mở liên quan đến 22 có một lúc cũng
được
Ừ Chắc để tách riêng ai đi à
hôm nay sẽ là update sport II
ở thời sự cập nhật nhiều sẽ để nó số
nhiều đi à
a tiếp theo
là liên quan đến kiểu view Cứ thử mà
đúng không
ở nhà đặt tên là update kiểu Nga cũng
được không sao
ảnh hưởng mấy con cùng lắm là ông có
thấy ghi rõ ra ông thích thì ông thể đi
rõ ra amin như thế này thằng Khang nghe
cho rõ
cập nhật cả bên xử lý nha tôi biết mà
ông quan điểm nha với tôi thì cái bên
bên con em nó không thay đổi lắm về mặt
logic mà lôgic ở Bắc em thành ra tôi cứ
thích cập nhật
Ừ cái này là tôi toàn hay gọi chung là
update
update in the Face mới thôi
hình ảnh
Ừ anh thấy thế cái view thì mới ông thể
đầy chung còn riêng và những cái này mà
mình cách riêng mà tự i5 xong rồi những
cái cái đó ta bây My trên nóng lạnh xong
rồi Mua đồ xong rồi mới đến lần lượt
những cái file khác
ông béo không thắc mắc gì thì một là mấy
ông inbox riêng hay là
buổi mới xong Nói chung là gần nhau
inbox riêng thì có cái gì hỗ trợ được
thì hỗ trợ nhé ở ngoài sao là kết thúc
đẩy đâu nha Trả lời không nhé á à à